but first our top story this hour takes
us to Washington where the U.S
government's ability to safeguard its
most sensitive information is under Fire
on Friday former vice president Mike
Pence acknowledged mistakes were made
after classified documents were recently
found in his Indiana home the
discoveries with Pence former president
Trump and President Biden have prompted
the National Archives to ask every
living former president and vice
president to check for classified
records but many in Congress are
questioning why the executive branch was
not more careful Christina raffini is at
the White House with the latest
Christina good morning
good morning Dana look experts we've
spoken to told us the more high ranking
you are the more likely this is to
happen that's because most people have
to go into a facility or a skiff a
secure facility to view these documents
whereas presidents and vice presidents
get to take them off site
mistakes were made former vice president
Mike Pence says he was not aware
classified documents were at his home in
Indiana until a few weeks ago but that
that was no excuse and I take full
responsibility
and I've directed my counsel
to work with the National Archives with
the Department of Justice and with the
Congress Pence says his team found the
documents after he voluntarily launched
a search of his property following the
discovery of classified material at
President Biden's private Residence at
an office he used following his time as
vice president this also comes after
about 300 classified documents were
recovered from former president Trump's
Mar-A-Lago estate we're going to handle
all the classified documents here
responsibly outgoing Biden Chief of
Staff Ron Clane was asked this week if
he's taking extra precautions to make
sure he's not packing up classified
material along with his office I don't
think people have to worry about that
but the seemingly pervasive problem of
unsecured sensitive documents does have
at least two people worried Senators
Mark Warner and Marco Rubio so somehow
the only people who are not allowed to
know what was in there are congressional
oversight committees the top Republican
and Democrat on the Intel committee told
cbs's Margaret Brennan they're unable to
assess if any of the misplaced documents
pose a threat because they haven't been
told what's in them the justice
department has had the Trump documents
about six months the Biden document's
about three months our job's not to
figure out if somebody mishandled those
but our job is to make sure there is not
an intelligence compromise
and of course those ongoing justice
department investigations are just that
ongoing Dana
all right
it is it is no there's no question mark
yes you are Christina yeah
thanks Christina